KORY JEFFREY: Hello, everybody.
We are in San Francisco
at Founder World.
I'm joined in the studio by
Kevin Holmes, the founder
and CEO of Founder Network.
Kevin, thank you for joining me.
KEVIN HOLMES: Thanks
for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's start
with, what is Founder Network?
KEVIN HOLMES: Sure.
So Founders Network is a peer
mentorship organization of 500
plus tech startup founders.
In three words, it's
founders helping founders.
KORY JEFFREY: So what
does that entail?
KEVIN HOLMES: Well,
like I said, we're
a peer mentorship organization.
So the way I unpack
that is advice
based on experience, warm
introductions, and then
moral support.
And so the way we facilitate
that is we have a platform.
We have a custom platform
that we push weekly updates
to-- a very engaging platform
with 90% monthly active users.
People are using
the forum there.
It's email based interactions.
And they're asking for help and
receiving help all the time.
And then in addition to that,
we do over 100 events a year,
mainly in San Francisco,
Silicon Valley, and New York,
but also in Vancouver and
other emerging markets.
And then the third thing is we
have a staff of eight people.
So we're always
looking at how we
can facilitate the network for
the members of the community.
KORY JEFFREY: And
these are founders,
so they have started their
own full time company.
They have founded it themselves.
KEVIN HOLMES: Right.
So one of the aspects
of Founders Network
is if you're going to
receive peer mentorship,
you want to make sure that
it's from people who know
what they're talking about.
So there's a ton of
great resources out there
and a lot of great information
about how to do things.
"The Lean Startup" is a
really well known book
that's often quoted
chapter and verse, almost.
But what we're really focused on
is actually creating liquidity
around the expertise of
the members in the network.
And so we want to make sure
they have good experience.
So we basically have
three membership criteria.
You have to be a founder.
It has to be a tech startup that
you're working on full time--
so you've taken
the leap and you're
committed to making it succeed.
And then the third
thing is that you're
invited by a current member.
So we are invite only.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
So the membership base
probably centered around
where you do events,
but sounds like it's
international as well?
KEVIN HOLMES: Good question.
Most of our members are
based in the tech hubs--
sort of what you do if
you're in Silicon Valley.
You start a company.
That's kind of the
expected route in life.
You don't buy a home.
We also have probably
20% of our membership
that's located all over.
And because we
have the platform,
they can engage online.
They don't have to jump
in a car or a plane
and fly to Silicon Valley.
They can get help
from other members
without leaving their
screen, basically.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
So do you have any favorite
stories about things
that have happened
on the platform
that you're really proud of?
KEVIN HOLMES: Yeah.
So one of my favorite
stories is we
have a feature called
anonymous posting,
where you can post
to the network
without revealing your identity.
And by and large,
we don't use it,
because it's a closed
community, and people
feel comfortable sharing
how they're feeling
and what they're working on
and those types of things.
But in this case, a member
was dealing with depression.
And so it was sort
of an edgy topic.
And people aren't always
open about talking
about those things.
More and more they
are, and that's good.
That's a good thing.
There's been a lot of talk
about founder suicide.
And Brad Feld of Techstars
has talked about that a lot.
But this member
talked about the fact
that he couldn't get
out of bed for five days
and had to tell his team.
Do I tell my team?
Do I not tell them?
They're going to
know something's up.
What do I do?
We have 500 members.
At least 50 people
replied on that thread.
And when you reply there,
you can't reply anonymously.
You have to come out
and say who you are.
And so many members said,
hey, I have depression, too.
I treat it like a handicap.
Here's how I deal with it.
It was my favorite moment
in four years of doing this.
It was so cool to see the
support and the community
and the realness of that, that
potentially saved this person's
life.
But also, everybody
else that had that
and is struggling with that
was able to talk about it.
So by far, that was my favorite
moment in four and a half years
of doing this.
KORY JEFFREY: That is
a pretty good moment.
I think that's an
awesome moment.
So Founder World.
KEVIN HOLMES: Yes.
KORY JEFFREY: Besides
sharing the name of Founder,
what has attracted
you to this event?
KEVIN HOLMES: Well, it's
a relatively new event.
I think it's the
first year doing this.
And when we saw
the opportunity, we
thought, what a
great way to connect.
Founders Network, our members
are founders of startups.
In fact, many of
them are here today.
So other people
that exhibited today
are members of Founders Network.
We have over 500 members.
This year, they're on
track to raise $250 million
in funding as a community.
So all stages, but also
really experienced.
So some of them are up on stage.
Some of them are exhibiting.
Some of them are just attending
very early stage as attendees.
So it's sort of a
no brainer for us
to be here and be part of it.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, makes sense.
So obviously, with having
that strong of a network,
you're going to have an awesome
cross section of technologies
that you kind of
get insight into.
Is there anything in particular
that excites you right now?
KEVIN HOLMES: Yeah.
One of the things I think is
cutting edge and exciting,
and also a little bit
potentially scary,
is this Knightscopes Technology.
And this is a member of Founders
Network, William Li, Bill Li.
He's a former automotive
industry executive.
And he started post-9/11, he
wanted to enhance security.
And so he's built sort
of an R2D2 mobile robot.
And it's awesome to see.
It's really friendly and cool.
And I think if
anybody's going to help
bring robotic
security to market,
it's going to be Bill Li.
So it's very exciting to see.
Of course, there's always
the tinfoil hat conspiracy
theories.
KORY JEFFREY: But
it's cool to see, too.
Because they're actually
out front right now, right?
KEVIN HOLMES: Yeah.
They're securing the perimeter.
KORY JEFFREY: They're
securing the perimeter.
That's awesome.
Favorite Google technology?
KEVIN HOLMES: You
know, that's something
that I could debate,
I suppose, for hours.
But I'd say Gmail by far and
away is what I use the most.
I had an argument or
a debate with someone
about-- they would say Calendar
is more important than Gmail
and is the anchor for
stickiness for Gmail,
which I thought was
an interesting case.
And then, of course, there's
search, which you almost
don't even think of it.
KORY JEFFREY: That's cool.
Well Kevin, thank you very
much for joining me here.
KEVIN HOLMES: Thanks
for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
KEVIN HOLMES: Pleasure.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you guys for joining.
We're at Founders World in
San Francisco, and I am Kory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]